die häufigsten
heute macht der chef sogar die fotos für
seine gäste klaus tworek hat sich in
südafrika als busunternehmer ein kleines
imperium geschaffen
in normalen zeiten bringen seine roten
doppeldecker die touristen das ganze
jahr über hoch auf den tafelberg und an
die schönsten ecken rund ums kap
das ist der tafelberg hier ist unser
stopp die toiletten sind hier drüben der
bus wird etwa zehn minuten hier stehen
wo wir weiterfahren
aber dieser sommer ist nicht normal für
den südafrikaner mit österreichischen
wurzeln ist die omikron variante ein
desaster die zweite corona saison in
folge wieder stornierte reisen wieder
keine gäste aus dem ausland
wir hatten natürlich ein recht hart
lockdown über die letzten paar monate 18
monate sodass hat sie sich gerade jetzt
hatte sich die situation
normalisiert und jetzt natürlich die
letzte krise mit der neuen variante
die unsicherheit wächst aber noch sind
touristen im land auch weil die
infektionszahlen hier in südafrika im
gegensatz zu europa weiterhin niedrig
sind
deshalb wollen auch florian und pierre
ihre schmuckstücke weiterhin jeden
morgen für alle gut sichtbar an die
straße im moment sind es vor allem
tagestouristen die mit ihren harleys an
der küste entlang zum cup der guten
hoffnung wollen von ihren kunden habe
keiner wegen omikron das land verlassen
[Applaus]
weil sie wissen was in deutschland
abgeht oder in europa wir haben auch
alle kunden aus holland frankreich und
österreich
keiner will eigentlich wirklich zurück
nach zwei jahren corona zwangspause
wollten pierre und florian diesen sommer
richtig durchstarten das ist touristen
aus europa und den usa jetzt so schwer
gemacht wird nach südafrika zu kommen
halten sie für übertrieben also scheinen
mir die maßnahmen in der geschwindigkeit
wie es jetzt gerade durchgesetzt werden
zu krass zu sein weil einfach die
ökonomischen effekte auf südafrika
momentan nicht kalkulierbar sind
am nächsten wochenende soll endlich die
erste große tour beginn sieben
teilnehmer wollen trotz omikron aus
deutschland und österreich kommen
helme equipment und motorräder alles ist
vorbereitet geplant sind zwölf tage
florian will die gruppe 2900 kilometer
quer durch das land führen
im moment können sie nur hoffen dass es
dabei bleibt und ihre zeit bis dahin so
gut es geht nutzen entlang der route
sind hotels und restaurants längst
gebucht wie stark südafrikas wirtschaft
von der omicron variante getroffen wird
hängt auch davon ab welche erkenntnisse
die wissenschaftler in den nächsten
tagen präsentieren
die arbeiten mit hochdruck an der
sequenzierung der neuen mutation wie
schwer die krankheitsverläufe sind
welchen schutz die impfstoffe bieten
darauf soll es in wenigen tagen
antworten geben experten befürchten dass
es nach omikron noch weitere varianten
geben wird
werden gemeinsam auch den rest des
griechischen alphabets lernen dass wir
besser vorhersagen können wie und warum
sich diese variationen entwickelt
gleichzeitig fühlen sich in südafrika
die impfzentren aufgeschreckt durch die
schnell steigenden zahlen die impfstoffe
sind vorhanden aber die menschen sie
zögern vor allem die jungen nur jeder
fünfte von ihnen ist vollständig geimpft
die krankenschwestern carlo kone
versucht überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten
angst und ungewissheit über die folgen
von omikron helfen ihr dabei
die neue variante breitet sich so
schnell auch das könnte schwere folgen
für südafrika haben schließlich hat es
hier angefangen
als krankenschwester hatten carlo kone
schwere krankheitsverläufe gesehen die
impf appelle der regierung gehen ihr
längst nicht mehr weit genug
die größten sorgen machen uns die
feiertage die menschen werden feste
feiern und die zahlen sind jetzt schon
sehr sehr hoch wegen der neuen variante
sollen sie es doch machen sollen sie die
leute doch zum instant zwingen
es ist sommer das schuljahr ist vorbei
prüfungen sind geschrieben partyzeit in
südafrika
wie in diesem club in soweto spielen
abstand und hygienemaßnahmen kaum eine
rolle dass sich die hochansteckende
omikron variante gerade über die
ungeimpften jungen verbreiten könnte
ändert wenig an deren impfskepsis
ich werde mich nicht impfen lassen das
macht doch keinen sinn die impfung
verhindert kein chor wird was also ist
der grund sich impfen zu lassen
lego kann darüber nur den kopf schütteln
sie will endlich wieder ein normales
leben führen und hat sich gerade zum
zweiten mal impfen lassen schuld an der
skepsis sind vor allem die
verschwörungstheorien sagt sie
schluss damit holt euch die impfungen
seid frei
in kapstadt lässt sich klaus lorig den
stand der wartungsarbeiten erklären seit
corona steht der großteil seiner 50
busse im depot und die zeit will er
wenigstens nutzen auch um seine leute zu
beschäftigen
von 245 angestellten musste er 200
entlassen
zurzeit wie es aussieht mit den letzten
mit der letzten krise jetzt mit der
letzten variante sieht es ja für die
weihnachtssaison nicht so positiv aus
das heißt wir fahren der nur mit
südafrikanern und das heißt wir haben
mit mit fünf oder acht wagen mehr als
genug wagen auf der straße
nicht leicht dabei den optimismus zu
bewahren aber klaus tworek steht jeden
tag auf und hofft dass sich die dinge
bald wieder zum besseren wenden